to anybody's wealthy every day okay I'm
not I'm going for the other one the
millionaire 20 bodies is man
Islam net is raising funds to establish
a Masjid and Community Center in Norway
and they urgently need your support this
donation will be a Santa for you because
every person that comes a step closer to
Allah through your donation you and a
child American award click the link and
donate what you can you have a girl that
you're interested in yeah
um she has 20 intimate Partners she's
been with before but she's very wealthy
and the second option is she has no
intimate Partners before but she has no
money she just relies on you which one
would you go for I think the second one
second option which is the basically the
one who has no intimate Partners but
relies on you okay why I mean
I'm not a woman that had
okay you have two options yeah you have
a woman who has no past but is broke
relies on you no one so basically she
has no problem she's never been intimate
with anyone she's the Virgin right and
she she's broke she relies on you second
option she's got 20 bodies but she's
very wealthy which one would you go for
so anybody's wealthy every day okay why
why what firstly yeah she knows herself
okay secondly she can pay for the nights
out so listen
[Music]
your wife has been with 20 months but
she's Rich your pasta supposed bro Man a
millionaire okay she's got 20 intimate
Partners trying to intimate Partners she
carries on with no no no no they're from
my past
it doesn't matter yeah yeah okay no
problem thank you that was it number one
she is a virgin she's broke she relies
on you yeah number two she's got 20
bodies she's been with 20 man you're
fishing are you okay buddy you want some
deep oxygen yeah so should I repeat it
yeah no I can't like I'm going with the
first goal if she's broke and she's a
virgin then that's that's me but if
she's got 20 bodies and she's got money
then Nana okay what happened to you bro
tell me I wanted to elaborate it's
because 20 bodies
man don't love the number 20. but if it
was a few less I would like the fact
okay
the fact that she's got some experience
okay so let me get this right yep you
you don't mind that some next man why is
it next man maybe it's great guys like
okay no problem 10 great guys have been
with a woman of your uh and and they
have given her that experience so you
don't mind envisioning your head that my
wife has been with 10 man great guys
great guys here has teaching her some
experience and she comes and does the
same thing with you so you have no
problem with that it's not the same
thing it's different every every section
okay why does it matter for a man like
you know as a man why does it matter
about your girl's past
part of romantic and if it's me that's
going to be with her then like I need to
know that I'm all right and that I'm
okay and that she hasn't been through
like a lot of men in that she's not seen
in that way you know what I mean like oh
my God to be easier
okay all right okay I appreciate your
honestly would you rather go for the
luxuries knowing that your partner's got
20 men that she's been with or would you
mind personally yeah personally oh would
you personally I'd go for the first one
which one is that broke okay the first
one is a virgin broke she relies on you
the second one as well she writes on me
she relies on it oh sorry I did it yeah
it is okay so I repeat again virgin
broke Rich 20 months she's been with 20
men intimately virgin birth okay a
virgin broke okay interesting no I don't
want to use the word but like just
trying to go for like a fresh tinting
yeah you don't want it because they said
many men you know not many men yeah
Excuse me yes
people like this if I said to you would
you rather have 50 Grand debt or that
the partner that you're with has been
with 20 men before which one would you
rather
option A not she's been with no one
option b same girl has got been with 20
intimate Partners yeah which one would
you go for one with 20. I'm so sorry
girl if you dreamed in your mind yeah
she's pink she's a Chong Ting a bum Ting
whatever you want to call it yeah I'm
gonna put her into two categories sorry
repeat again virgin bro oh she's been
with 20 guys slept with them but she's a
millionaire the Virgin brood virgin
okay good good so man's watching Andrew
take still
okay which one matters to you the most
foreign
[Music]
bodies
so when we take the money factor out you
will prefer her to be a virgin so the
money is
okay I would say that in all honesty I
would I would select the one with zero
sexual partners in the past and I can't
tell you exactly why but I know that
some of my upbringing and some of the
other social factors that are at play
have affected that and then there's also
an element of my uh my innate
propensities she's virgin broke or she's
a millionaire but she's got 20 and she
had 20
I want yeah
yeah because because you need to
understand a woman is different this is
very interesting because a woman is
wired differently we're not the same
yeah I'm trying to say so that's why
they if I said to them the sky that
you're going to be with yeah in the
future is going to be broke most girls
are gonna be like just the way we judge
them by their past they judge us by our
future and it's just it's just it's not
our fault it's not something we just
wide like that
okay
broke or the second option she's a
millionaire but she's been with 20
months she's got 20 bodies ah no virgin
bro I don't know
[Music]
so guys today we came to Chef's Bush and
we did a social experiment the purpose
of this social experiment was not to
demonize one gender or another but to
truly understand how a man and a woman
thinks and what they prioritize in each
other and that is what is really
important because the more we understand
each other and how we are unique in our
own way and we have our own unique
things that we look for in the other
gender we would have a better future
that is the reason why we've done a
social experiment this is in no way
shape or form to demonize a brother with
a pass or a sister with a past or a
brother with his future child and sister
with his future but the aim is that we
understand each other and that's the
main thing inshallah and in Islam those
who repent all their sins are forgiven
and it's a new beginning but this is to
just understand how a man thinks and
understand how a woman thinks that was
it hope you guys benefited from it it's
been cold it's been freezing but I
really enjoyed it until next time
to catch you if you would like me to do
more social experiments like this
different topics comment in the section
below Islam net is raising funds to
establish a Masjid and Community Center
in Norway and they urgently need your
support every person who prays there
every kid that learns about Islam every
youngster that memorized the Quran all
of this and so much more can be only a
scale of Good Deeds click the link and
donate what you can and share the video
for even extra reward